und dann also quasi nach natürlich
machten nacht bin ich dann aus dem zug
ausgestiegen und habe mich so was von
wach gefühlt mit diesem einen trick das
war richtig richtig komisch ich konnte
mir selbst nicht erklären zu hause ist
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft heute spielen wir jump liege
und wm-titel gesehen habt habe ich euch
heute eine kleinigkeit zu erzählen und
zwar quasi ein tipp von mir wie man
kurze nächte oder gar nicht lange nicht
wie man kurzen kurze nächte mit ganz
wenig schlaf übersteht und gleichzeitig
noch eine reallife geschichte kombiniert
wenn ich heute ein bisschen würde da
liegt es daran dass eben die nacht sehr
lang war und der schlaf quasi gar nicht
existent wo fangen wir an
ich war gestern in berlin
heute morgen aber ich bin gerade erst
angekommen bei mir zu hause so vor einer
viertelstunde und hat mir jetzt kommt
man nämlich auch liege für heute auf
damit die heute muss man schauen hat
folgendermaßen ich war in berlin auf
einer party und bin kalifa gestern abend
vor gestern bin ich zu einem kollegen
nach köln gefahren und habe dann in köln
übernachtet und dann gestern morgen den
shuttle genommen von köln nach berlin wo
die party war das so dann kamen wir dann
alles chillig was heißt alles chillig
also die fahrt von köln nach berlin
einfach acht stunden gedauert
ich hab' ich hasse bus fall also leute
ich bin wirklich kein mensch der bus
fahren gerne macht ich glaub ich würde
dann doch lieber einfach alleine mit dem
auto fahren das ist einfach schilliger
für mich leute ist nach so vielen neuen
kurs die hatte schon die wohlgemerkt
schon der nacht in köln also bevor ich
dann von köln aus den schotter nach
berlin genommen habe relativ wenig
geschlafen also fünf stunden waren es
glaube ich für ein bisschen weniger also
knapp unter fünf stunden ist es für
meine verhältnisse schon ein wenig also
dann habe ich schon eigentlich zu wenig
schlaf sohn sind am nächsten tag nach
berlin mit dem shuttle ich hab halt ewig
gepennt so alles easy und dann abends
besagte feier übrigens relativ viele
youtuber wand lustigerweise am
wahrscheinlichen getroffen
ganz witzig und dann ging er hat sich
diese feier einfach so ewig lang gezogen
also ich glaube die vier feiert sich
bist ja also ich war um 11 da ca ja ich
will kamen so um halb acht in berlin an
aber ich hab dann noch paar dinge
versteckt mussten doch meine hallo meine
tasche ablegen und es ist einfach ein
ewig zwar richtig krass langer tripcke
da sitzt dieser parcours ja so schön
wunderbar und deswegen habe ich einfach
durch es um 11 uhr für party sein
das war ein bisschen luft würde ich
früher da sein aber egal dafür habe ich
natürlich dann umso mehr gas gegeben man
kennt ist klar man kennt ist während mir
vertraut man kommt später auf die party
als seine kollegen und dann geht man
erst mal bissel gas steht ihr was ich
meine
übersteht ist schon da unten ich glaube
ja ich bin im kopf drin
doch relativ lang gefeiert denn die sind
ein bisschen 5 uhr und dann habe ich
mich auf den nachhauseweg gemacht und
ihr müsst wissen dass der nachhauseweg
einfach eine stunde in anspruch nimmt
ungefähr richtig krass richtig krasse
berlin also ich hatte darin ganz ganz
ganz ungünstigen schlafplatz aber war
kostenlos also beim bekannten gekommen
aber sehr sehr sehr weit außerhalb
deswegen hab ich eine stunde hin
gebraucht und dann nehmen wir haben
sechs die party verlassen summen 7 dann
zu hause und mein trick ist einfach das
hat mich richtig krass gewundert
ich bin dann in der s-bahn rausgefahren
eck bahn übrigens die gehört mir
wenn jemand damit fahren will muss an
meine erlaubnis erst mal ein wohl ich
bin gefahren und dann bin ich einfach in
der s-bahn eingelegt so ich wollte es
nicht wurde ich wach bleiben aber man
sitzt halt und ist so legal fertig vom
feiern und dann legt man einfach weg so
ganz normal
nick aber zu dem weg wird steht ihm ein
und dann bin ich eingeschlafen und ok
nice ich kriege einfach gerade eine
abonnement meldung von einem anti viren
programm kannst du bitte aufhören
behindern aufnahme zu nerven
norton anti krebs
und dann bin ich eingepennt so und dann
habe ich aber gar nicht lange geschlafen
ich glaube es waren so maximal 10 bis 15
minuten am stück und dann also quasi
nach natürlich machten nacht bin ich
dann aus dem zug ausgestiegen und habe
mich so was von bach gefühlt mit diesem
einen trick das war richtig richtig
komisch ich konnte mir selbst nicht
erklären
also ich glaube es geht einfach darum
dass man dann für einen kurzen zeitraum
einfach die augen zumacht war kurz
einschläft also zehn minuten
man sollte nicht in irgendwelche
tiefschlafphasen verfallen
also man eine stunde schläfer so dass es
deutlich zu lang also zehn minuten haben
tatsächlich gereicht so dass ich mich
dann beim aussteigen aus die züge
richtig richtig krass war gefühlt das
war extrem also nach zehn minuten das
hat auch den ganzen tag dann vorgehalten
kann so bis zum 11 als der bus land
zurück fuhr extrem wach gut aber muss
auch darauf achten dass man die ganze
programm hat also ich wollte die welt
gar nicht warum ich tipps zu durchmachen
hat sich bakken gebe leute wie gesagt
ich bin einfach ein bisschen geschädigt
von dieser sehr kurzen nacht hat dann
natürlich im fuß auf dem nachhauseweg
noch bisschen geschlafen aber trotzdem
ich hab auch let's play so einfach mal
hier so lange laufen voll aber schon
eine ganze weile nicht mehr gemacht
deswegen sind es sicher keine
bestleistung aber ich hoffe mal dass es
trotzdem in ordnung das ist so bist du
mein tipp also wenn ihr irgendwie eine
nacht durchmachen muss dann mal ganz
kurz gegen die decke springen des fcv
ganz kurz die augen zumachen so 14 15
minuten anhalt auch ich würde mir dann
lieber wecker stellen so dass es da
nicht zu krass verpennt und
komischerweise hat das sensationell bei
mir funktioniert also ich bin
normalerweise niemand der einfach so
easy peasy nächte durchmachen kann gibt
es auch kollegen von mir die sache klar
mache ich aber zwei nächte durch ich
kann nur noch schlafen
nee das kann ich nicht ich bin wenn ich
so eine nacht durchgemacht habe richtig
fertig aber da ging es und danach habe
ich hat immer dafür gesorgt dass ich
dann programm hatte weil wenn man nein
als ob ich das schon wieder verkaufe es
gibt es noch nicht wenn man dann
programm hat den ganzen tag dann bemerkt
man die möglichkeit auch nicht ja wenn
man sich darüber mal hinlegt oder hin
setzt man zur ruhe kommt da
trifft es eine tatsächlich discobeats
okay gut und dann gut der bussen zurück
dann habe ich natürlich im bus die ganze
zeit geschlafen die vier stunden
gebraucht hat von von berlin tatsächlich
hat der bus zurück kürzer gebraucht als
der bus hin nach berlin was vielleicht
auch daran lag dass ich in ein andern
ort gefahren lernen aber wer weiß das
schon okay leute ist es einfach so krass
ungewöhnlich weiß nicht warum ich muss
ein richtig lang kein pvp male gespielt
haben kann es sein
also hat jetzt mal letzten sky wars in
der für die kreditaufnahme aber sonst
hält neues stepping ist halt immer noch
verlassen
ich weiß gar nicht so dumm man weiß
nicht ob es ein pinker ist vielleicht
war es auch einfach geht
als wäre mein vorname weil mein nachname
kill with skill das hatte die noch vor
sachen zack immer gebrauchen an
gefährlich nach aber alles klar
mit dem einschalten schwert habe ich dir
alles drin
aber ja wahrscheinlich wird die ganze
zeit durch ok-chef oder haben an dem
frauen aber ist hier und wir haben so
viele so wie sie es bei dem aus mein
lieber besteht lage bei der ich hoffte
versteckt sich jetzt gerade nicht
ich hoffe durch dich nicht verstecken
sonst wird spaltet wo ist der typ da
kann man was anfangen nur noch wut so ok
bin ein gegner wir müssen aber versuchen
jetzt mit einer wegzukommen
das gefühl du bist unsere einzige chance
so leute ach ja übrigens ich habe es so
läuft vor dem bogen alles klar natürlich
will ich selbst kann eben schon mal
angemerkt
das ist richtig schwer
der deutlich bessere rüstung hat 81
punkte hätten sie aber eine ordentliche
eine combo auspacken wenn ich ihn haben
will
vor allem jetzt wo ich sie überhaupt
nicht in minecraft cvp tritt mit acht
leute übrigens eine frage wenn ihr das
hier seht dann danke schön
dann schreibt man in die kommentare ob
ihr mal bock auf einen rock it liegt
lets play hättet ich habe mich mir
beziehungsweise max ich brauche
max hat sich rocket league geladen und
ich hab das mal angepackt und ich finde
rocket liege richtig los und ich glaube
dass ich da auch nicht so
grottenschlecht bin also es geht schon
mal weg jörg einfach gut was was etwas
erwarte ich eigentlich
ich weiß aber nicht ich wer nein nein
nein lolli sie aber diese double hits so
okay jetzt habe ich nur noch ein leben
er hat halt ein fucking übertriebenes
equipment wie seid also rocket league
wäre das sehen wollt gerne in die
kommentare
dadurch schon bock drauf ja dann schießt
du deinen fall du hast doch schon vor
den op ist dave so dankeschön meine
eltern auch ein schweizer
warum
macht das sinn nein so als ob er auch
noch eine fns hat es gibt es nicht ob
ich holen
ich hole ich schwöre was für ein krasses
equipment alter intense okay let's play
gelernt sein
ich muss erst mal wieder hereinkommen
aber ich wollte heute unbedingt video
für euch machen ich hoffe dass wir mit
diesem tipp für etwas anfangen können
ich würde es eigentlich nicht unbedingt
machen also wird sich ausprobieren wenn
sie wirklich nötig ist weil das fast
schon ein bisschen ab aber das ist ein
bisschen mein geheimnis was ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch öfters anwenden
werde
wenn ihr gerne mal eine pepsi betrinken
wollt dann schreib mir die kommentare
die wurzel von 64 wir sind zunächst
video wieder